This video is brought to you by Squarespace,
from websites and online stores to marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the only one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Check out Squarespace through the link in the description below more on them in
a bit
Aviator war hero, Nazi connections,
family scandals murder. When you hear the name Charles Lindbergh,
you likely think of his themes.
33 hour flight across the Atlantic is custom-built plane. The spirit of St.
Louis is said to have pushed forward the bounds of mechanical aviation and his
expertise was a vital importance to the American military in the Pacific during
world war two, lauded by many as an international hero,
Lindbergh's carefully controlled public persona certainly presented him as such,
but there was a shady secretive underbelly to this larger than life figure,
which in the few moments that exposed itself during his life,
it caused him international controversy.
The man born Charles or Augustus Lindbergh was a pioneer of early aviation,
an author, an activist,
and to key consultant and combatants for American forces during the height of
world war II. What many often overlook as Lindbergh would have wanted where his
isolationists, eugenesis ideals,
the mystery kidnapping and death of his infant son,
and as the eight illegitimate children,
he fathered with multiple women in Germany to quote the youngest of these
children after Lindbergh's death.
This story reflects absolutely Byzantine layers of deception on the part of our
shared father. These children did not even know who he was.
He used a pseudonym with them to protect them perhaps to protect himself.
Absolutely even whilst on his deathbed Lindbergh wrote letters across the
Atlantic,
urging his mistresses to keep quiet as elicit activities to coding facts from
fiction is a tightrope walk when examining such a full life yet even the simple
facts, more than surprising in regards to this Titan of 20th century.
[Inaudible] Detroit.
February the fourth, 1902, Charles Augustus Lindbergh is borns Evangelian lodge,
land Limburger high school chemistry teacher, and it's Charles August Lindbergh,
who would go on to be a us Congressman throughout most of Charles's youth,
representing Minnesota in the house of representatives.
The elder Charles was one of very few congressmen do oppose us entry into world
war one. He would go on to write, why is your country at war?
I've got critical of us entry into the great war.
The Minnesota representative is minority,
but lexical views would have unforeseen consequences on his son's life,
but more on that to come with his parents divorcing when he was seven,
Charles moved around often during childhood,
never attending any school for more than two years after graduating high school,
Lindbergh began attending engineering school at the university of Wisconsin,
Madison, but he dropped out during his sophomore year and moved to Lincoln,
Nebraska to pursue flight training in the spring of his 20th year,
Charles has an innate interest in mechanical engineering and zap liens in
particular as he reached adolescence,
but never had he been exposed to aviation until enrolling in the Nebraska
aircraft corporation's school in Lincoln,
gaining his first flight experience there as a passenger and copilot Limburg
soon left the school to and money in order to learn to fly solo,
to earn the cash sheet needed.
Lindbergh worked as a barnstormer performing death-defying aerial stunts,
such as wingwalking on planes.
Mid-air before transitioning into airplane mechanic at the airport in billings
Montana by 1923,
Lindbergh purchased his first plane home $500 there's surplus world war one,
biplane nicknames, Jenny almost immediately.
He began flying solo and barnstorming from the Jennie under the Monica Daredevil
Charles,
after showing off his aerial stunts across the Southern us for the next few
months,
Daredevil Charles decided it was time to commit fully to piloting somebody
enrolled in the year-long flight training program offered by the United States
army air service in San Antonio,
Texas early aviation was anything but safe and only 18 of the
104 who enrolled in the program finished it a year later,
Charles was among them despite suffering a mid-air collision with another cadet
during aerial combat maneuver drills just eight days before he was due to
graduate Linberg was able to attract and parachute out in time. And fortunately,
this would be the most serious accident Charles would have through the rest of
his aviation career, graduating top of his class,
and in Bergen's a commission as a second Lieutenant in the air reserve service
court upon completion of his training,
and then learning that additional active duty pilots were not needed.
Charles returned as a civilian piloting as a barnstormer and flunked instructor
by participating in a limited fashion in military flights in his spare time,
Lindbergh was twice promoted to Lieutenant and then to captain by 1926,
during this formative period in the mugs life,
he also became an ML pilots in order to raise money for assumed to be at fame to
custom built plane.
[Inaudible].
A wealthy Brazilian businessman living in New York names.
Raymond I'd heard about the first successful nonstop transatlantic crossing in
1919, which was completed by a duo of British pilots.
The flight was 1,900 miles and impressive feat,
but only about 60% of the distance between New York and Paris inspired by this
achievements and wishing for more efficient transport between the two world
cities oughta put up a prize of $25,000 awarded to the first to fly
nonstop between New York and Paris.
The prize had a five-year time limits and when no one completed the seemingly
impossible feat within the allotted time or to renewed the prize for another
half decade, by the time Auti renewed the prize in 1924,
a number of well-funded and famous world war one pilots of several nations were
attempting this monumental task.
ACEs from Europe and America alike gave it their best effort,
but they all ended in catastrophe and death exemplifying the perilous nature
of undertaking this fetal competition, Charles Lindbergh,
a relatively inexperienced and anonymous ABA drew at the time caught wind of the
prize referred to as the Orteig prize Lindbergh decided to enter the race.
Despite the stiff competition,
Lindbergh found it difficult to secure funding for his gold,
but while working on his ML route between St Louis and Chicago in 1926,
he convinced to St. Louis businessmen to fund his endeavor.
Charles felt confident he could win the Orteig prize due to his experience in
both mechanics and piloting,
just like having substantially less financial support than his competitors.
San Diego based rod aircraft company agreed to build the plane.
And it was to be named the spirit of St. Louis in honor,
of the finance seers upon Charles insistence.
They agreed to allow him to co-design the plane as well.
The main engineering difference between the spirits of some Louis and its
competitors was it's designed with launch a fuel tanks and no second seat for a
navigator,
a two man team of pilot navigate and made all other attempts at transatlantic
crossings. But Lindenberg reassured the uneasy Ryan aircraft company.
He could handle both jobs by himself by removing the space for the second seat
and replacing it with an extra fuel tank. The spirits of St. Louis was lighter.
Runs had more range than its competitors. Early in 1927,
the aircraft was complete. And after some flight tests,
including a trip from San Diego to New York Lindbergh's team deems the spirit of
St. Louis ready to attempt the transatlantic crossing in may of 1927.
That same month themed world war one flying is shall new guests.
Aaron's navigates a Francois early disappeared over the Atlantic,
attempting to capture the Orteig prize,
the loss and presumed death that Francis most decorated and famous pilot to date
cost further doubt over the less funded sins,
less established Lindbergh attempt on may the 20th, 1927.
The spirits of some Lewis with Charles at the helm took off from Roosevelt
airfields in New York, spanning the ensuing 33 and a half hours,
a completely alone Lindsburg overcame,
icy and blind flying conditions flew above a storm at 10,000 feet.
And as low as 10 feet over wave tops do avoid the harsh weather of the North
Atlantic because navigation techniques were unreliable and primitive by today's
standards. And Lindbergh had no communication with anyone.
He relied solely on dead reckoning to estimate his position during the flight,
by sheer luck, the winds over the Atlantic,
essentially nullified one another that day,
negating any potential wind drift and miraculously keeping Charles on course
around 33 hours after departing Roosevelt, airfields are freezing,
exhausted and hungry.
Linberg spotted his intended target of [inaudible] airfield outside of Paris,
unbeknownst to Charles,
a crowd of approximately 150,000 Brazilians flocked to the airfield to see
lands.
And the headlights from their cars acted as a beacon for Lundbeck safe landing.
As soon as he touched down in Paris on the evening of may,
the 21st Charles Lindbergh had gone from virtual anonymity to a worldwide
aviation hero of unprecedented scale.
[Inaudible].
The level of fame that surrounds a Charles Lindbergh was staggering in a single
day,
shortly after the heroic flight to New York city hosted a ticker-tape parade.
And then a ceremony for Lindbergh who was seen in person by some 4 million
people that day, the French foreign office flew the American flag in them,
bugs on her, a symbol of respect, reserved solely for foreign heads of state.
Up until that point and December, 1927,
Lindbergh was awarded the congressional medal of honor by president Calvin
Coolidge and especially sign of respect due to the fact that it was the highest
military combat on a one could receive the following month time magazine crowns,
Charles man of the year, the youngest ever recipient of such an honor.
These are just a few of the many awards that Limburg received representation of
just how much recognition and adulation he received for enhancing the
possibilities of aviation using his newfound fame and subsequent fortune from
speaking doors and pending an autobiography.
Charles shifted his focus towards scientific exploration,
Lemberg designed a wristwatch that when used concurrently with the sextons and
nautical Almanac allowed fellow aviators to determine their exact longer toot
jaws presented as designed to the laundry you wash company.
And they began production in 1931,
the same laundry navigation watches are produced to this day with GPS navigation
only recently making them obsolete as a result of his sister-in-law developing a
fatal heart condition.
Lindbergh became curious about the possibility of performing surgery on the
heart. Those such procedures did not exist at the time.
Charles studied outside of body perfusion procedures with Nobel prize winner,
Alexis Carroll,
the unlikely duo found the results of best study encouraging and thus developed
the glass perfusion pump, which Charles nicknames,
the model T pump and homage to his friend Henry fought this glass perfusion pump
led to the creation of the first ever heart-lung machine.
And it is also wanting to be credited in making future heart surgeries possible.
Considering his lack of expertise in the medical field and the impact of the
model T pump had on medical advancements.
This feat of engineering was perhaps as impressive as Charles as transatlantic
crossing five years prior. And if you're looking to do something impressive,
well, let me tell you about a great way to get that out to the world.
That's where the website with today's sponsor Squarespace. Now,
maybe you've got an idea for a website or a business or a podcast or something
knocking around in your mind. And you're like, well,
I'm thinking about doing that. Should I do it? Well?
The second thing is that the only way to figure out if it's a good idea,
and if people want to listen to you to buy your product,
whatever is to make a website and get it out there into the world.
And that can be daunting because it's scary to go and pursue new things,
but not knowing how to set up a website is not an excuse.
There are no excuses available with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to
you. You want to sell something online. Yes. Set up a store with Squarespace.
You want to start a podcast. Totally. They do that too.
It all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template that you can customize to
your heart's content,
or start from scratch or move over from an existing domain,
whatever you like on Squarespace, everything is easy to manage.
And once you've gone through the super easy customization process,
there are no updates. There's no patches. There's no tech BS to deal with.
And Squarespace also handles all of the website. He stuff like I say,
they do podcasts, but also main in this social integrations, all of that stuff.
This is also 24 seven customer support. Then to help you,
if you've ever got a question, had to squarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics and you'll save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain.
[Inaudible].
Charles Lindbergh was internationally celebrated as a hero.
He did not enjoy all the attention that came with his stardom in order to escape
the masses and settle down into family life Lindbergh purchased in the state in
Hopewell New Jersey.
It was here that he intended to raise his first child Charles Lindbergh Jr.
With his wife and Mara Lindbergh. However, on the fateful night of March,
the first 1930 to 20 month old Charles InBev Jr.
Was abducted from his crib at the family estate in Hopewell,
the anonymous kidnapping note demanded a $50,000 ransom equivalents to over
$900,000 in 2020, and hoping to catch the kidnapper.
The ransom was paid with bills with recorded serial numbers and gold
certificates. Soon to be removed from circulation,
both of which would attract attention if used by the abductor,
commonly regarded as the crime of the century,
media outlets worldwide picked up on the story details of the case became
increasingly public.
As time went on and local and federal police generated thousands of leads for
suspects all across the country. 70 days after Charles Lindbergh Jr disappeared,
his decomposed remains were found in the woods less than five miles from the
family estate. The case was far from over.
How are those J Edgar Hoover head of the Bureau of investigations worked closely
with the New Jersey state police to hunt down the murderer for two and a half
years, no suspect was identified as the culprits, but finally,
the gold reserve notes,
recirculated and law enforcements linked to the notes to Bruno Richard Hauptmann
carpenter who immigrated from Germany 11 years prop helped him in his
handwriting sample matched the ransom note and more of the rents and money was
traced back to him. He was charged with first degree murder,
tried convicted and sentenced to death in 1936.
Bruno Hoffman was no more having faced these same,
that fatal consequences that he imposed on Charles Lindbergh Jr.
The only silver lining of this heinous crime was that Congress enacted the
Lindbergh law in response to the atrocity.
You making kidnapping a federal offense.
If the victim is transported across state lines,
or if the male law interstate commerce is used to elicit a ransom.
[Inaudible].
Charles Lindbergh was an intensely private man despite his worldwide celebrity
status after Sumption atrocious attack on his family,
that caused fear for the safety of his three-year-old son,
Limburg decided to quietly leave the United States for England in December,
1935, the Lindbergh family boarded a United States freighter is the only three
passengers headed for Liverpool for three years.
The family lived in a rented home in Liverpool before, again,
relocating to the Breton coast of France in 1938.
It was during these years that Lindbergh's controversial political views began
to emerge between 1936 and 1938 in the years leading up to world war II.
The us military sent Charles and Berg Germany to evaluate German aviation.
Several times by 1938 Lindbergh was friendly with top-ranking Nazi party
officials like Herman Gehring Geminis at chief,
and one of Hitler's top advisors that same year Gehring presented Lindbergh was
the commander cross of the order of the German Eagle and Charles gladly accepted
this prestigious owner accepting the award proved controversial due to the
infamous Kristallnacht pogrom.
Essentially kick-starting the Holocaust just weeks up when writing in his
private diary, Lindbergh admitted that Germany had a serious Jewish problem,
but he did not understand why they would attack Jewish businesses and homes.
So aggressively and only in 1939,
us general HH Arnold requested that Charles returned to the United States to
evaluate the American army Accor readiness for war should such measures become
necessary. Although we have made the orders of general Arnold Lindenberg,
starkly opposed us intervention and what he deemed a European conflict in
August, 1939,
Albert Einstein selected Lindbergh as the pilot needed to deliver an essential
message to president Roosevelt,
warning him about the destructive potential of nuclear efficient Lindbergh
ignored Einstein's request. And days later,
he delivered a radio address condemning us intervention in the war.
Linberg also sympathized with the German plight as well as implying antisemitic
conspiratorial views about Jews controlling public perception of the war.
Two months later,
Lindbergh criticized Canada for supporting Britain in the fight against the
Nazis and dragging the Western hemisphere into the so-called European war.
By the ends of the following year Linberg was the spokesman for the America
first committee,
a political action group focused on non-intervention in world war II.
He delivered speeches to packed arenas across the United States with a message
that three groups were to blame for pressing this country into war, the British,
the Jews and the Roosevelt administration in response to this heavy criticism,
president Roosevelt denounced Lindbergh's attitude toward war is cowardly and
appeasing the Nazis as well as questioning his loyalty to the American flag in
the face of such public criticism from the president,
Lindbergh felt he had no choice, but to step down from his military posts.
In addition to opposing the war against Germany,
Lindbergh also had strong naughty assistant eugenesis ideals,
and he spoke openly about how he felt certain races were superior to others.
In one particularly alarming quote,
Charles stated that racial strengths is vital politics,
a luxury furthermore, Henry Ford,
to the automobile tycoon and publisher of an antisemitic newspaper famously
stated when Charles comes out here,
we only talk about the Jews while these racist viewpoints are deplorable to
modern society.
The unfortunate reality of the day was that Lindbergh's mindsets about the
existence of a racial hierarchy with Nordic races at the top was not
uncommon and enjoyed social acceptance by many others.
[Inaudible].
The attack on Pearl Harbor in December, 1941,
left the United States with no choice,
but to enter world war II Lindbergh's ever-growing non-interventionist movement
was derailed.
The moment Japanese bombs landed on that December morning in Hawaii,
despite his leaving military service Lindbergh still wished to show his
patriotism and support for the military during combat.
So we offered his services as a consultant between 1942 and 1944,
Lindbergh operated,
stateside ironing out kinks in the production line for forwards B 24 liberate a
fighter plane,
and then the United aircraft as an engineering consultants by 1944,
Charles was itching to prove his worth in a true combat environment.
And he persuaded United States to send him to the Pacific theater,
to examine aircraft performance in combat conditions immediately showing his
aviation knowledge was an assets Jones taught combat pilots.
How to safely take off with a double payload of bombs.
Limburg also demonstrated the safest technique for leaning fuel to increase the
range fighters could fly on one gas tank vessel allowing for more long distance,
Boeing raids against the Japanese.
These innovations were vital in American success in recovering the Pacific and
Linberg was tasked with teaching them to countless American fighter pilots and
both flew his first combat mission within months of arriving in the Pacific,
despite holding no official rank or title.
John subsequently flew 50 combat missions in the P 38 lightening fighter on many
of which he bombs targets and reportedly even shot down Japanese fighter planes.
Maureen Lindbergh had four more children after the war was over while living in
Darien, Connecticut,
even some 20 years after its historic transatlantic crossing,
Charles was in high demand and he only saw his children a few months out of the
year.
He served a number of enterprises as a consultant from the chief of staff of the
air force to the private company. Pan-American airways later in life,
Charles moved to Hawaii where he focused his efforts on environmental causes,
such as protection of foreign, dangerous species, as well as the Messiah tribe.
And the loss of Africa earns the tacit eight people on the Philippine islands of
Mindanao.
He also established a national park on the Hawaiian Island Maui during the
post-war period of Charles's life.
You also make numerous trips to Europe and yes,
another controversial endeavor involving Germany between 1958 and 1967,
Charles fathered seven additional children to three different mistresses in
Germany. Two of whom were sisters.
These seven children were completely unaware of their father's true identity as
he would only visit them once or twice a year using the pseudonym. Kara again,
even when laying down on his deathbed,
Charles wrote letters to his three German mistresses,
urging them to keep quiet about Israel identity and adulterous behavior.
It was not until over a decade after Charles Lindbergh's death in 1974,
that is illegitimate daughter Astrid discovered her father's true identity by
reading a magazine article about him shortly thereafter. She,
after approximately 150 love letters from Lindbergh to her mother,
along with some photographs to DNA tests in 2003 confirmed asteroid suspicion,
and she made the news public causing a media storm in two separate chapters of
Lindbergh's life. He engaged in secretive activities involving Germany,
whether the strong Nazi affiliations in the years leading to global conflict or
the seven unclaimed children, he fathered two decades later.
It is clear that there are certain aspects of Charles's life that he wished to
keep privates each time. These events surface,
they caused conflicting feelings among the American people about who Charles
Lindbergh is. The man really wants. In many cases,
it is possible to detach a public celebrity from their personal activities as
Joel's would have hoped that as this dark secret spilled onto the front pages of
the newspapers,
this proved impossible for a man whose political and personal ideals, constant,
a long shadow of doubt over such a full achievement rich.
And I really hope.
You found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
just like this a few times a week,
and please do support our fantastic sponsors Squarespace. They are linked to.
Hello. Thank you for watching.